on peyton this is first
the penalty so none looking to
capitalize but rose and quickly
coming in as a as a duo
that court duo interesting was going to
say i would i would have been shocked to
see rose come in ahead of quickly
not because of you know what they've
accomplished in their career but the way
the season has gone and
you know so much talk about will rose is
coming to the next
effect quickly's development
affect quickly's minutes but to see them
come out in the court this might be very
interesting well
the thing is kim's
derek rose double something that he'd
have been doing a lot more of a lot more
effectively jonas quickly
drills the three your percentages go way
up when you catch it in your shooting
pocket stepping in towards the basket he
went five minutes without a field goal
the knicks come back and score easily
that's the rookie
ob topping the dig in defensively here
hard dive cutting you see what derek
rose can do off the bounce really
setting up his teammates getting inside
drawn bam just enough to drop that one
off of the dunk back to back
a very poor shooting three-point
shooting team outside number 29 out of
30 teams and makes an attempt
out there it's a score in the paint oh
the value of derek rose being felt
already by the new york knicks just
created that turnover he could be a
great role model for our young players
jenny defends
he penetrates he dishes tangibly as a
player and then i think what you
mentioned you know as
leadership trying to mentor some of
these young guys we see the tangibility
right there being able to get a steal
the top scoring defense top field goal
percentage defense
top three-point percentage defense this
year and burks
drills a quarter triple leveling on the
offensive end
coach spo going to put in jimmy butler
here on the next stoppage just to
try to steady this team they are really
right now a laser beam from
derek rose he has seven points points
will do that for you as
burks misses from three robinson hustles
to the rebound he's a very good
offensive rebound
rose that looked like it was guided in
derrick rose miami's gotta try to steal
this tip
not that time here comes rose against
robinson
derrick rose scores derek rose in the
second unit on the floor right now for
the next heroes pull-up blocked by derek
rose
win and then come home and win that
series it was it was a great
great turnaround to be down 3-1
derek rose knocks him a jumper 13 points
for rose tonight